Chris Mannix covers the NBA senior NBA
rider from Sports Illustrated his most
recent column and si finally the NBA has
a format now the real work begins Chris
good morning how are you what's going on
Dan
well I'm trying to figure this net
situation out I've always felt
everything I've read is that Durant
would not be coming back we'll start
there do you think Durant is going to be
coming back I don't and I think it would
it would take an incredible reversal of
direction for Durant to come back you
know how to talk to people about this
within the Nets organization I've talked
to you rich climb and Durant manager and
every conversation I've had has not left
left me feeling like the door was even
open for something like this to happen I
mean if it was a shoulder injury or a
Steph Curry like broken hand you could
have a different conversation but you're
talking about the most significant
injury an NBA player could have and then
taking that player and dropping him
after seven eight regular-season games
in a three week training camp into the
most intense atmosphere an NBA player
can go through and you know all I think
about when you're thinking of that
scenario is didn't we just do that with
Kevin Durant like ditched us you know
with a major injury to his calf come
back and then in one game
Papa's Achilles I mean the Mets have a
four-year investment in Kevin Durant
even if he came back I couldn't make the
Nets a favorite you don't come back from
an Achilles injury and look like the
same players you once were so what is
the point in rolling him back out there
and it's truncated season postseason you
know just to roll the dice and hope you
catch lightning in a bottle though I
it's gonna be an incredibly long layoff
for Kevin Durant once the next season
starts but the the risk to me then and I
think that the Nets and Kevin Durant is
not worth the reward given the fact that
we have you know a smaller postseason
eight games regular season
going in give me one or two teams that
you think and with no home court
advantage that this team might play the
role of spoiler either in the east or
the west well to me it's Philadelphia in
the east and you know the fixers had
plenty of problems this year even before
you know Ben Simmons went down with that
injury but Ben Simmons is coming back
and you know that you know we always
thought when it came to the Sixers that
a defensive minded team that doesn't
rely on shot might have a shot in the
postseason on up-tempo necessarily high
volume Creek shooting team like these
playoffs almost are built for a team
like Philadelphia like when you have
teams coming back you're just not going
to be able to you're still sharp enough
to be the kind of perimeter shooting
team that you were proud of this a lot
of these players have not been even
doing much in the way of one-on-one work
some of them have been shooting for the
better for the last couple of months so
you're gonna see a lot of college
basketball like shooting numbers I think
in the regular season in the postseason
if you're Fidelia you don't q3 this is
you don't care you you are a defensive
team you want to you want to play ninety
style basketball where games are in the
eighties and nineties so I look at the
Sixers you know their chemistry is
always issue but but talent perspective
this might be perfect for them like they
could wind up being a team and not only
wins the first round series but yeah
they could make a run all the way to the
finals like I think that this is just
one of those weird scenarios it sets up
really well for Philadelphia
wait are you doing this because you know
me McLovin is so excited what McLovin I
told you and I take a back I said don't
don't book Maddox today you know and now
I think it's totally paid off both Matic
thank you for laughs I appreciate that
is it fair to is it fair to the Lakers
in Bucks that there is no home court
advantage for these two teams
considering what they did during the
regular season it there was no way to
give them something for for what they
did during the regular season no it's
not fair life's not fair I mean it's the
way it goes in
climate and you know there are all these
suggestions you read about some of them
they're even more from the people I've
talked to you about finding ways to
you'll give teams that had home-court
advantage whether it's an extra
possession or little things like that
but what you heard out of Silver State
last night
lines up with some of the stuff I've
been writing for last couple of weeks
the NBA
sadly wants to protect the integrity of
the playoffs and Michael Jordan said
this to Adam silver and out of Silver's
belief is all along you don't want to
screw around with gimmicky stuff wants
to get to the playoffs because that's
threatens the credibility of the
champion so if you want to fight another
possible but if you want to find a way
of shipping Blaker floor to Orlando and
playing games on it great like do that
but that is as far as it goes when it
comes to giving them an advantage I
don't know if it's the floor as much as
it is the fans that you need to ship to
give these teams their home court
advantage how about you just send Jack
Nicholson and a fan to be named later I
mean I'm all for sending like the super
fan of everything down there like clever
Darryl you know in the the stands can
imagine his voice with echo in an empty
arena like send then somebody go for
each team but this is just I mean you
know this is just the way it goes like
you know this is the best of a bad
situation there's no way to fix it or
make it any more palatable so teams you
have to deal with the consequences
talking to Chris Mannix from Sports
Illustrated senior NBA writer how is the
NBA going to issue press credentials how
do people get into cover and do we have
broadcast teams who are going to be able
to cover this you know I know for a fact
it's still being negotiated right now as
far as what kind of press access is
going to be I mean I would imagine that
if you want to cover the playoffs in its
entirety you've got to put yourself in
that bubble and you have got to agree to
effectively quarantine yourself for for
three months and that's you know
difficult for a lot of people to do I
mean maybe not so much for me I have no
life whatsoever slightness you
for a lot of people you know you have
families you have reasons to be in and
out of there so I think that is that is
going to be a challenge there's a lot of
interest in front of print media
perspective in being part of covering it
but the NBA is understandably leery
about letting people come in and out the
question of broadcasting I don't know
that's been fully resolved yet but
people have talked to have been under
the impression that many of these
broadcasts will take place remotely
whether it's from Bristol or you know
and Lance up or Turner you know I think
that certainly is a fluid situation
right now but over the last couple of
weeks that was what I was hearing when
it came to how games be broadcast during
all this yeah I think it'll be via
remote for the national broadcast and
even local broadcast the NBA season if
there's a game seven would end on that
Monday night in mid-october and then
there's a quick turnaround and the
Commissioner talking about starting the
2021 season on December 1st seems
aggressive
why start December 1st with games why
not wait till Christmas well starting
December 1st is all about finishing like
end of June you know it's all about
trying to recalibrate the schedule in
one season like they don't they as of
now they don't want to play into the
next summer so if you start December 1st
you might have to sandwich some games
closer you know do some things you don't
necessarily want to do with spacing but
you can get back on a regular calendar I
think it I think it's a mistake and I
think it's one that as you saw Michelle
Roberts already commented on this like
you're gonna have a human problem with
negotiating that type of quick
turnaround but I think the NBA's got an
opportunity here then to start the
season on Christmas when most people
start caring about basketball anyway so
use that as your launching point and
then play into the summer on a regular
schedule try to get some valuable data
to see if summer basketball actually
works if the ratings go up if getting
away from the NFL actually makes some
sense
if it doesn't and your rating plummet
for one year okay end of August which is
when a December star would probably put
you you can find a way to get back on
track in the 2021 2022 season but right
now I think it's a golden opportunity
for the league to do what a lot of
people internally already want to do and
something they can chalk up to the
pandemic and that doesn't even include
the fact that it's good business to push
even further down the line to get fans
potentially back in the stand for next
season
who's your prediction well I started
this whole year saying the Lakers
wouldn't make the playoffs or at least
would be more likely than not do not
make the plan so I'm gonna take the
Lakers to win the whole thing to a
complete complete 180 but I saved in I
am gonna go on the limb and I'm gonna
say Lakers Sixers in the finals okay
you're not picking your Celtics huh good
like I look at the Celtics and I look at
the Bucs and I look at how reliant they
are on the three-point shot like that to
me is a big variable in all this like
how are these guys what kind of skills
are these guys gonna have when this game
comes back like the [ __ ] giannis of the
shoot threes but everybody else does
like that's a five out seems like they
want everybody else but Jana is behind
the three-point line launching and if
you're missing a lot and that leads to
like one of the fixtures do well they
forced misses and they play up and down
in transition but don't shoot threes
don't even shoot long too as well but
they get up and down in transition and
create opportunities and that's why I
think Philadelphia if they're if Simmons
as well and their act together I think
they could have a bigger run did you
care about this CBS poll about the
greatest shooters of all time I mean not
really you it's obviously subjective so
yeah it was on the list at this point
well it was
let's see klay Thompson Steph was number
one klay Thompson I think I was too bird
was in there Reggie Miller in there
Ray Allen was in there and probably
Kevin Durant was in there it's like it's
like pipes
shooters though right like you know
Steph Curry like greatest off the
dribble three-point shooter I've ever
seen
Ray Allen may be the best standalone
3-point shooter I've ever seen what
Reggie could do in clutch moments and
you know the best of both worlds in that
way it's just you almost have to you
know break it down to silos and say
here's the best this type of three-point
shooter yeah I know it's meant to have
us get riled up and argue and nobody's
arguing with Steph Curry klay Thompson
might be a little recency biased he's a
wonderful shooter how did everybody miss
on klay Thompson when he was in
Washington State that's a good question
I don't think they saw him as being like
he was a very good defender a very good
three-point shooter but I think if I
think back to what was going on back
then I think they saw him more as
one-dimensional I don't think they saw
him being and becoming a complete player
that he was then he was still a lottery
thing like he was still a well-regarded
player but I don't think they saw the
diversity of the skills that clay kapha
was shown in his time as a pro I
remember Mark Jackson the former Golden
State head coach was we had a private
conversation and this is when they were
thinking about Kevin Love for clay Tom's
straight up yeah and I said man that
gives you a whole different look you
know he can shoot threes he can rebound
he goes klay Thompson is the best
two-way guard in the NBA and I went
really goes in my opinion he goes we
would never even consider that trade
yeah they really didn't either on Golden
State side that I mean it's been
documented well over the years but they
didn't really give that more than enough
not quite I mean again you see guys be
great defensive players in college I
don't think anyone saw clay for coming
to stop her that he became in the pros
but we can like there's so many like
almost how about Kevin love for OJ Mayo
happen that was lopsided deals in draft
history yep I was right there Paulie and
I were arguing and I said Kevin love's
ceiling 15-8 you know OJ Mayo might be a
guy who can get you a 20 25 you know
play some defense
and that didn't go hey I hate to say it
then but I was kind of having the same
argument you were at the time like more
towards male you have to remember to the
Kevin Love back then was like doughy
like he just didn't look like he had he
didn't have an NBA body and there were
people at the time that you know I once
teemed like expressed to me they thought
Kevin Love might have an eating disorder
like that he's never you'll be able to
develop a kind of body that he has
developed that made him a great NBA
player so crazy Kevin loved her for
turning his entire physique around in
the objec and a no J male average 19 is
rookie year he was first team All Rookie
but Kevin Love improved himself he got
got better you know the fact that he put
in a 30-30 night man you just never know
Dan like what you can pet like it's hard
as hell work ethics on 18 year olds
right like you you can see them doing
stuff you know in high school and in
college you can talk to their coaches
but until you get them in the gym for
like year one you don't know what their
dedication is going to be and that's
that's what most difficult parts of
scouting players you can see the talent
and try to project out the talent but
did you know the Kevin Love was going to
become this workaholic that would you
know turn him his body into one of the
better NBA physiques and turn himself
into one of the better frontcourt
3-point shooters I mean he just put the
time in and you can't really project
that when it guys are young thank you
Chris enjoy the weekend we appreciate
your time as always
you got Dan that's Chris Mannix Sports
Illustrated NBA senior writer